12-time Olympic medal is Ryan Lochte is
suspended again from competitive
swimming for violating an anti-doping
rule the US anti-doping agency banned
the pro swimmer until july 2019
for exceeding the permitted amount of an
IV infusion of vitamins now this is
locked EES second suspension in less
than two years CBS this morning Saturday
co-host Dana Jacobson is here without
social media led to the ruling Dana
makes you wonder what's he thinking good
morning that is exactly what it makes
you wonder good morning Ryan Lochte says
he got the IV full of vitamins earlier
this year to help bolster his immune
system but no surprise when he posted
this photo with his wife at an infusion
clinic on May 24th it prompted an
investigation by anti-doping authorities
nothing that I took was illegal Ryan
Lochte waded back into controversy
Monday conceding that he broke the rules
as an athlete but was very clear the
substance he took through an IV was not
illegal you can get at CVS Walgreens
public like you name it you can get it
there are just vitamins um but there's
there are rules IV infusions of more
than 100 milliliters within a 12 hour
period have been prohibited both in and
out of competition since January 2018
it's the process of flushing your system
so this is a method that can be used to
mask the use of some sort of illegal
substances Wall Street Journal senior
sports writer Rachel Bachman covered
Lochte at the 2016 Rio Olympics the
bottom line is he's a professional
athlete someone should have told him or
he should have known this is what he
does he's a veteran Olympian Lochte is
still dealing with the fallout from
filing a false police report in Rio he
already served a ten month suspension
and could still face criminal charges in
Brazil he says this new ban is
devastating for his family as soon as
you get to a certain point or level in
any kind of sport career you're always
going to have a I on you and I think
I've learned it the hard way despite the
setback Lochte still plans to compete in
the Tokyo games if anything this will
make me more hungry and I'll definitely
be there
20:20 well if he qualifies Lochte will
turn 36 years old at the 2020 Olympics
that would make him the third oldest US
Olympic swimmer ever to compete in
individual events but the suspension
will certainly limit the amount of time
and number of meets where he will be
able to qualify an aura study the rule
book all right Dana we're on a route
warm Nora but he keeps suffering from
self-inflicted wounds yeah but he to
blame but himself
yeah it's one scene